that croissant blueface I I think it's
sad that we're consuming it and watching
it in real time this [__] reminds me of
Whitney and Bobby it's like we're
watching this train wreck and we know
it's going to end bad and like all we
just keep doing is promoting and sharing
it like it's really hard to look the
other way man it's like every day it
gets a little bit crazier but it's like
she hits a verbal and physical abuse and
we're just consuming it as entertainment
that's just crazy and now there's a
pregnancy it just keeps getting elevated
and elevated and elevated it's very hard
to look away I'll be honest it's like I
know that by watching these videos I'm
in some way contributing to this but at
the same time it's a car wreck you see a
car crash on the side of the [__]
highway you're gonna look at it you're
gonna look at it and
yeah it's tragic but there's somebody
close to both of them steps in and like
they have to separate at the
fact that they thought it was all
orchestrated I thought that too yeah it
just felt surreal they just started that
reality show and I thought they were
Hamming [__] up for the reality show but
are they making money from the thief in
some way they're monetizing the reality
show I think he is a patreon that he
does his like um
like a Bad Girls Club but right for him
so I'm like any person that is able to
break it I was probably getting money
from it so I'm like they don't have any
incentive to break it off like anyone
with the authority over them to be like
yo really didn't and I wonder if they
can tell the difference because they're
getting so much clout from it they're
getting talked about so much and if
you're in entertainment it's very hard
to
you know
um disassociate you know it's very hard
to just even distinguish between
content and just positive reward you
know like when you're making music and
then people like it that's awesome but
then you start doing these other things
and then you're getting tons of views
and it's like okay I'm getting that
feeling that I always liked when people
are talking about me also people just do
that in relationships like I don't know
what their childhood or like what their
upbringing was like but like if your
parents were unstable and now your girl
is like going crazy and like trying to
hit you and [__] then you're just like
oh that's proof that she loves me yeah
and so like that's all you know yeah if
that's the case I don't know what his
upbringing was like but like then you
might not even know anything's wrong so
people are like hey why do I need to
step in if there's no problem and we're
making money off it tell also I do think
as a dude there's you're like yo you
worry that your girl is hitting you dog
like I think there's some level of light
come on bro stop being a [__] yeah
yeah yeah like it's just not just I'm
not saying wait what's logical or what
most people would say but there's a
voice there's a contingent of people who
would be like yo you upset about a girl
hitting you it's a girl oh yeah and then
as a guy you need a you don't need that
much of that to be like all right I
guess I'm I can't be a [__] that brings
loud for a guy other guys being like yo
you [__] yeah a thousand people could
be like you're not but if ten are like
you are you're like [__] dude I gotta
prove I was 10 wrong
side I hope somebody splits them up
before
one of them is no longer here you think
it's like that yeah I think it's really
yeah oh damn yeah I think it's from from
each other or I think it's a combination
of drug use and the physical assault is
gonna escalate yeah yeah I think it's
getting worse and worse I didn't know
maybe fighting fighting the old
Christian video maybe you showed me when
she was like a track and field like a
Collegiate she used to be back yeah it's
you see it's got to be drugs has to be
nothing else explains like the
appearance
what's how it's transformed